y pues creo que el mensaje aquí es muy
claro no la postura de netanyahu es
seguir adelante con con esta propuesta
de reforma que está planteando a pesar
de las voces que ha habido dentro del
propio gobierno no el ministro Job galán
va a ser el más
vocífero en este sentido Pero otros lo
han hecho el mismo presidente de Israel
que eso se ha mostrado en contra de esta
reforma sobre todo que sea más pensada y
moderada que no vaya a ser tan expresa
su realización pero creo que en tanyahu
va muy claro en en este sentido y
obviamente cuenta con todo el apoyo del
ministro de seguridad interior y tamar
bengario no que es el que principal
iniciador y promotor de esta reforma
judicial y pues vemos que las protestas
que ya llevan bastante tiempo de la
población israelí no han surtido
demasiado efecto en calmar esta
intención de reforma judicial A qué se
refería el ahora ex ministro de defensa
galán cuando dijo que las divisiones
causadas por esta reforma podrían
amenazar la seguridad de Israel
Pues en realidad se refiere Justo a
cuestiones internas
esto permitiría sobre todo que las
reformas que se plantearan a la ley
básica recordemos Israel no cuenta con
una constitución y se rige a través de
leyes básicas que las emite la propia
necesidad que es el el órgano
parlamentario únicameral solo existe un
un órgano
parlamentario en en Israel y eso
permitiría al gobierno poder realizar
todas las reformas que quisiera y en
caso como es en la actualidad que la
suprema corte es la responsable de
revisar y dar un visto último sobre esta
reformas
esta reforma lo que permitiría sería que
si la suprema corte se opone a estas
nuevas leyes o reformas legales que se
que planteara el propio parlamento
la podría
una vez que la regresara al parlamento
el propio parlamento podría rechazar
estas controversias que planteara la
suprema corte y se irían aprobadas las
leyes no Y esto evidentemente le daría
muchas
libertades al al propio gobierno no
encabezado Pues siempre por el Primer
Ministro y entre estos intenciones no y
aquí seguramente lo que está hablando
galán Pues bueno viene esta reformas
algunos de los de los principios de lo
que se podría beneficiar sería
que ciertos grupos principalmente los
judíos ortodoxos no hicieran su servicio
militar no Y esto pues mermaría no eh al
al poder militar que sabemos que es muy
importante en Israel además
favorecería
o permitiría poder dar paso a estas
leyes que buscan la expansión completa
territorial y promoción de los
asentamientos en territorio palestino y
esto sin duda pues incrementaría las
tensiones con los grupos palestinos e
Israel bien usted lo mencionaba hace un
momento ya son varios las voces que se
alzan contra la reforma judicial del
Primer Ministro benjaminé tanyahu hay
críticas dentro del mismo partido y
también se reporta descontento dentro
del ejército Qué pasará en Israel con la
figura de benjamita Yahoo quien ha
insistido en seguida adelante con su
reforma muy brevemente por favor
sabemos que cuenta con el apoyo de una
gran parte de la de la población a pesar
de que estas muestras
en contra han sido muy visibles y las
vemos en los medios de comunicación como
ustedes lo han mostrado pero también
cuenta con otro apoyo no Y cuenta con el
apoyo de los Ultra ortodoxos es una
parte importante En este gobierno sin
duda Va a ser complicado poder echar
atrás seguramente tendrá que haber un
cabildeo ahí importante pero va a ser
interesante ver cómo va a terminar esta
situación